i like the gold chain thank you
you know trying to be cool getting out
of 1883 for a little while honey you
don't need to try to be cool
you got it
um luckiest man here i mean is she
beautiful or what i mean my wife is just
smoking yeah i mean and you two together
hot damn well you know i'm hanging on
for dear life but other than that yeah
yeah it's good you guys just surpassed
25 years what do you mean hold on for
dear life yeah it's good it's we're
we're looking for tonight for everybody
to see this because we're really proud
of it it's such a special project and uh
i mean it plays like a
10-hour film you know so i'm looking
forward to everybody soon look at her
back there i know look at her
she's badass are you like that proud
instagram husband absolutely yeah i've
got so many great pictures that she
won't let me post
he's taking the devil he was just
talking about how proud he is of you and
how hot you are and how lucky he is
well same you guys are heating up this
red carpet in chile las vegas that's for
sure
it's chilly right it is chilly past is
amazing yeah we're so excited some of
them we haven't seen
in a while but this is fun yeah just a
great bunch of people yeah how much
trouble are you all going to get into
all together here in vegas
so much trouble we can't even share with
you we got to get up early so i don't
know how much trouble we can get into
but you guys are exhausted we still have
work to do
well congratulations on everything you
both look amazing tonight and i wanted
to ask you about the wardrobe in 1883
what was it like stepping back into 1883
fashion
she had the most trouble
the corsets wow
okay a whole new respect for the women
back then honestly um
not only courses but layering and
layering of things uh the costumes are
amazing everyone i mean janie and her
incredible team that worked in the
costumes
says everything it allowed us to
be present
step into character and it truly is even
though they're
not always so comfortable to wear
but that's okay you know uh it made it
uh allowed us to be where we needed to
be i thought we should have been in
costume when we came here it's just a
whole lot easier throw a head on and a
bunch of mud on your face and you're
fine yeah
did you have marks on your body when you
would take the corsets off girl i have
stories for days i had marks ribs i had
a rib at a place up here
for real here's the hardest thing
with her especially but with all of us
we have guns and chaps and button flies
on and when it's cold we have longer
just to pee
just to go pee
is like an adventure how long would it
take well it takes a while and
and if you make it you're lucky
take me a while i'll just do what you
got i was like give me some scissors i'm
gonna cut some i'ma cut me a hole and go
for it now listen y'all didn't need much
wardrobe for that bathtub scene okay
there wasn't much involved in that hey
you're right
come on girl now you said that scene was
difficult for you even though it's
alongside this guy your husband it was a
little difficult for you because i'm
modest you know that's kind of yeah
anyway they made it easy easier than i
thought it was going to be and it's a
beautiful scene and it turned out great
well i can't wait for everyone to see
1883 come to life on our screens very
soon and right after we've got the
holidays coming up you guys are
celebrating your 25th christmas together
what is what is the plan this year
sleep
well we got a little decorating to do
when you get home you have some
decorating i have sleeping today okay so
decorating and sleeping no he will be
helping and you're making the pasta
right that's the tradition i got to make
the pasta for for christmas eve so
you guys are busy and you're off time
enjoy the holidays congratulations on
everything and i hope you guys get some
rest thank you so much you too you look
gorgeous i love the ponytail we both got
the ponytail yes girls like what you do
when you know we get much time right no
we put the pony in
[Music]
you